ces anonymes qui nous secours
qui sont ils parmi eux parmi elles les
infirmières à guéret au centre
hospitalier elles ont une école en deux
ans si tout va bien elles seront
diplômés d'état l'école a été créée en
1963 à la suite d'un voeu présenté par
le docteur ferrand président de la
commission médicale consultatif
à cette époque l'école était prévu pour
35 élèves
or il n'y en eu seulement que 23 et est
l'échec non aujourd'hui elles sont 105
il n'y a pas de garçons à cette école
cinq candidats infirmiers se sont
pourtant présentée au concours cette
année ils ont été éliminés
la profession d'infirmier reste
l'apanage des femmes elles sont donc
presque cinq fois plus nombreuses qu il
y a quatre ans pour monsieur bican
directeur du centre hospitalier
l'intérêt de cette école est à la fois
local et national
il ya un intérêt certain en ce sens que
les infirmières et qui sont formés à
l'école d'infirmière à guéret vous
permettre d'avoir un effectif toujours
comble l infirmière à l'hôpital
et cette école n'a pas été créé
uniquement pour l'hôpital de guéret et
bien entendu elle ne participe à
l'échelon national à la formation du
personnel paramédical puisque d'abord le
département nos élèves infirmières et
qu'ils ont reçu diplômes d'état peuvent
aller travailler dans des hôpitaux du
département qui en ont besoin est
également là certains services publics
les centres de protection maternelle
infantile et dispensaires le centre de
transfusion sanguine et puis également à
l'échelon national puisque beaucoup de
nos jeunes
nous avons travaillé également dans les
hôpitaux de la région parisienne ou dans
les grands centres où il en manque
la suite de leurs deux ans d'école
certains élèves reste-t-elle chez vous
oui selon les besoins de l'établissement
ce n'est pas un grand centre hospitalier
nos besoins à l'infirmière sont quand
même assez d'unités chaque année par
exemple cette année nous allons garder
six ou sept infirmières de la promotion
qui va sortir ou diplôme d'état qui se
passe actuellement limoges et comment
nous avons une quarantaine d'élèves qui
passent leur diplôme d'état voyez la
possibilité que ça donne envie aux
établissements pour pouvoir recruter des
infirmières étaient ont été formés chez
nous à guéret l'enseignement se fait en
deux parties des cours théoriques par
des médecins ou des pharmaciens et puis
les stages hospitaliers 16 heures par
semaine plus quatre heures de soins
ces stages hospitaliers permettent aux
infirmières de mettre en pratique les
cours théoriques que comporte le
programme d études mais ils leur
apprennent à connaître la psychologie du
malade
cet être si sensible à porter cependant
de leur féminité
elles apprennent entre autres choses a
interprété une radioscopie et le centre
hospitalier de guéret dispose d'un
service important d'électroradiologie et
d'électrothérapie équipe et anas et
pouvant répondre aux examens les plus
délicats
le bloc opératoire où sont donnés les
cours d'assistance de chirurgie
fonctionne sous l'air conditionné et
climatisés il est pourvu d'un matériel
très moderne avec un amplificateur de
brillance et un circuit intérieur de
télévision qui permet par exemple de
contrôler la réduction des fractures
être infirmière c'est certes une
vocation mais la vocation ne suffit pas
il faut répondre à un certain nombre de
critères d'adressent de technicité d'âge
aussi eh bien il faut avoir 17 ans et 8
mois au moins au 1er janvier qui suit
l'entrée à l'école d'autre part il faut
à niveau de culture générale valable
c'est à dire que pratiquement le
baccalauréat dispose hexavalent très
celles qui ne sont pas titulaires du
baccalauréat doit obligatoirement subir
un examen d'entrée qui est tout de même
du niveau de première
la pédiatrie et la spécialité que
préfère généralement les élèves
infirmières qui apprennent à donner le
biberon même à l'intérieur d'une
couveuse
une femme est toujours maire
les règles à respecter sont avant tout
celles de l'hygiène l'instinct maternel
et dans le bébé s'endort bercé par la
jeune hélène
et
elle s'est aussi les distraire
elle s'est aussi les consoler voilà
vraiment une profession féminine en 63
quand l'école a débuté il ya les 23
élèves cette année va y en avoir 120
à quoi attribuez vous ce succès et bien
d'une part un débouché certain pour les
élèves pour les infirmières donc pour
les jeunes creusois et d'autre part au
succès de l'école une infirmière
diplômée n'a pas de problème d'emploi
oh non il n'ira pas probablement voir so
lu ment pas